Hmmm I have a weird craving for liver and
fava beans...
Hey hungry fans, Julia here for DNews
Cannibalism: if you’re a Hannibal fan you’re
not squeamish around the subject of people
eating other people.
But it’s one of the biggest taboos in human
history.
But not in nature.
Sometimes it’s a family affair.
Mothers eat babies, babies feed off mom: a
"mom eats dad".
Other times it’s warring factions of the
same species, like chimps in Gombe National
Park who ate neighboring group’s offspring
as described in a study published in the journal
Nature.
But why don’t humans do it?.
Well simply put: it's not socially acceptable…
there’s no real reason why we don’t.
But come on, just the thought of it is just…
repulsive.
And with good reason, it can cause nasty diseases
like prion disease, which we know of as CJ
or mad cow disease.
Prion disease is caused from a misfolding
of protein molecules in the brain.
Which can happen for a variety of reasons
like a fluke of genetics or eating contaminated
meat.
The misfolded proteins will spread until the
brain is basically transformed into a "sponge”
riddled with holes!
It eats away at memory, causes seizures, and
it’s ultimately fatal.
While incredibly rare now, prion disease might
have been more common.
And this is where things get interesting.
Prion diseases might be rare now thanks to
cannibalism.
You see researchers found that another tribe
in Papua New Guinea has a genetic mutation
that protects them from prion disease.
The tribe used to practice funerary cannibalism.
Where members of the tribe would eat the remains
of the deceased rather than burying it.
The men would eat the “best” meat, the
meaty muscles, while women and children ate
less good meat, the brain.
Not surprisingly, they were devastated by
an epidemic of what they called “kuru”,
a prion disease.
At it’s peak in the 1950s, the epidemic
killed 2 percent of the population every year.
As the tribe became westernized the cannibalism
stopped and kuru began to fade into memory.
But those that were left behind developed
a genetic resistance to prion disease according
to a study published in the journal Nature.
The study found that this resistance is the
result of a mutation where the body produces
an amino acid valine rather than the more
common glycine.
This change prevents proteins in the brain
from producing the misfolding prions.
But a similar mutation might have happened
before, often.
A study published in the journal Science showed
a different mutation in the same tribe that
also prevented prion disease in another way.
But more shockingly, they found widespread
evidence of this mutation.
It was found in most humans from Europe to
Japan.
The researchers suggest that most early humans
practiced some form of cannibalism and probably
suffered massive epidemics of prion diseases.
And hence, why a large portion of the world’s
population has some projection from these
diseases.
But protection from disease isn’t the only
um… benefit to cannibalism.
In a study published in the Journal of Human
Evolution, researchers found that 800,000
years ago, our ancestors did, the killed and
ate the young of neighboring tribes as part
of a territorial defense strategy.
As the young of neighboring group wanders
far from home, they might attack and kill
the young as a kind of warning to the other
group.
This sort of defense strategy can be seen
today in some populations of chimpanzee.
But defense and warfare isn’t the the only
reason for cannibalism.
Simple hunger might drive people to dine on
their neighbors.
Another study published The Journal of Human
Evolution suggested that eating a group member
can help conserve energy.
One of the lead authors of the study told
Discovery News "The body can give one day
off from hunting, which was always dangerous
at that time”.
And I mean a human body contains a lot of
calories.
According James Cole, a professor on human
origins at the University of Brighton puts
the calorie count of a whole human body at
about 81,500 calories.
So uh yum.
So that’s fun news, eh?
Now as you watch Hannibal you can be proud
that it celebrates your heritage.
Oh man, nope.
Still extremely disturbing.
While you might be grossed out by cannibalism
some new moms are eating their placentas.
To get the whole sticky scoop, check out this
video right here.
So there you have it folks.
Humans… ate other humans.
We love to break down the weird stuff here
at DNew, so if you’ve got any weird questions
floating around that brain of yours, leave
‘em down in the comments below.